اليوم سنخصصها لمنصه تويتر حيث سادت حاله
من الفوضى منصه بعد بدايه منح اشاره
التوفيق المدفوعه حيث استغل بعض الامر
لانشاء عدد من الحسابات المزيفه حملت
اسماء شخصيات مشهوره واثارت جدلا واسعا
وظهرت حسابات موثقه حملت اسماء الرئيس
الامريكي السابق جورج بوش ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني السابقلير واللاعب الامريكي
جينز الذي اعلن الحساب المزيف عند رغبته
في الانتقال من فريقه قبل ان يكتشف الجميع
انه ليس حسابا لاعبي الاصليه
هذا وقع لنا مالك تويتر الجديد لهم ماسك
في تغريده له بدات تنفيذ الفعلي لاليه
تعديل التغريدات على الموقع عبر تغريده
معدله حملت كلمه جيم اوفر واظهرت التغريده
امكانيه التعديل خلال وقت محدد
هذه التفاعلات ونبدا من ما كتبه جاك
لورينز حيث تقال بانه استغرق مني الامر
اقل من 25 دقيقه لاعداد معرف ابل مجهول
الهويه باستخدام الزيتي ان واا البريد
الالكتروني القابل للتصرف وارفاق بطاقه
خصم مع العنوان والحصول على حساب موثق
لشخصيه بارزه فقد فكر فقط فكر ما اذا يمكن
ان تفعله دوله قويه او جهه فاعله سيئه
في كتب يعد حساب حساب ايلي ليلي على تويتر
الذي تم التحقق منه باعطاء الانسولين
المرجاني الناس يحتفلون بهذا لقد دفع شخص
ما
لثو ثمانيه الدولارات لند ماسك
وكتب عمر حرقوص قائلا سنوات طويله في
صناعه جديه في صناعه جديه موقع تويتر
باسبوع واحد تم توثيق الحساب شكرا
معنا من مدينه سيندونج جنوب بريطانيا
والجايات الخبير في شؤون التكنولوجيا
والتواصل الاجتماعي اهلا بك سيد جايات هل
مالك الجديد لتويتر وهنا على تحديدا السيد
الى الماسك يعي ما يفعل في هذه
المنصه ام عكس ذلك
وربما اغنى رجل في العالم ولكن لا يبدو من
افضل اصحاب
تغريدات التي تحدثت عنها بالنسبه الى
تغريده عمر حرقوص عن ضياع سنوات من الجهد
باسبوع واحد صحيحه اشياء كثيره تغيرت في
تويتر وهي تتغير كل ساعات قليله كل يوم
لدينا تغييرات جديده والفوضى عامه
ذكرت تضيع سنوات من المصداقين هذه المنصه
كويس
للاسف ليس لدي جواب عنه البعد قد يقول ان
السبب هو ان الى المسك اصلا لم يشا ان
يشتريها وهو ارغي مع علي ان يشتري المنصه
بسبب قرار المحكمه ولكن ما يحصل هنا كما
يبدو انه خلال ايام او اسابيع بدات تنهار
المنصه هي لم تكن يوما مثاليه ولكن كثيرين
كانوا يحبون استخدامها ونحن وصلنا الى
شفيري مرحله
نجد فيها انسحاب الكثير منهم منظمات
وافراد كبار منها
هذه الخطوات المتتاليه من قبل
ان يتوقع يتوقف عن تنفيذ خطوات من هذا
القبيل ام انه سيستمر باعتقاده
ايسنج
يعشق القرارات الجنونيه هو يحب وحده
التغييرات الضخمه التي تترك انتباعا التي
تدفع
قنوات مثل قناتكم المحترمه الى استضافه
تحدث
موظفين هكذا ينشر الامور هو يحب هذه
اللعبه
وهذه المره نحن نرى انه وجد لعبته وهو
يكسرها مع اننا نحن كنا نحب ان نلعبها
الخبير في شؤون التكنولوجيا والتواصل
الاجتماعي شكرا جزيلا لك